[Music]
Lionel you're in New York When the Smoke
From the Canadian wildfires made it over
there but you didn't close the windows
why was that
well first off the the air from outside
was the same as they are inside I mean
we had to breathe something
the way it works so I didn't think
keeping the windows closed made much
difference uh
more controversially I did go out and
play three hours of tennis each day that
the
you know the doomsters were telling us
to hide in our beds and I lived to tell
the tale
so um
I mean I don't have asthma or anything
so
uh it didn't seem that risky and the
point you make in your column uh
ultimately when it comes to These Bars
is that there is a tendency to blame
lots of these events on climate change
why is that well I've just noticed that
in the last few years especially uh
Whenever there is a weather event of any
sort it gets blamed I would have to say
quite lazily on climate change and uh in
the olden days meaning perhaps about
five years ago uh you would at least
have had to call someone on to the news
to verify that who seem to know what he
or she was talking about but not anymore
um now we can just call anything that is
disagreeable in the atmosphere or the
geosphere uh climate change and
um I think that ultimately this
backfires because it starts to sound
like propaganda
uh that's because it is if it's not
backed by any uh
causal science and uh it starts to sound
like background noise I know I realize
that this is politically motivated and
that we're supposed to be uh convinced
that not only is climate change
somewhere off in the future but it's
happening right now but
uh because because the attribution is so
careless uh it it doesn't actually help
the cause and in the case of the
wildfires it's it's just inaccurate uh
they were started by lightning strikes
uh the wind then blew very hard in an
unfortunate Direction and therefore a
lot of little fires that were started
that would have otherwise gone out got
fanned
um and then there was this weird high
pressure low pressure high pressure
thing over North America which is
apparently a rather unusual construction
didn't have anything to do with climate
change it's called an Omega block
um and that explained why that all that
smoke ended up coming to the Eastern
Seaboard but you know all over New York
um media uh newscasters and and
colonists and even the mayor of New York
just said you know this is this is all
because of climate change and you know
if you don't mind my saying so they're
talking out of their r's
Cliff do you agree with that
well most of the things I agree with all
although one thing I would disagree with
was about the air quality it was very
bad at points I mean extremely serious
air quality and playing tennis outside
in that air was probably not a good idea
okay I admit it was a little stupid and
that that wasn't a good idea and the
other thing is and the air inside the
building could if it had a circular
circular circulation system going on
like air conditioning or whatever it
would have filtration that would have
made the air a lot better inside so so
just as a as some advice you know you
don't have air conditioning there's no
circulation at all there's no uh if you
have a heating system you put it on uh
you put you shut the heat down but let
it recirculate air that can make the air
much much better so anyway so that
that's just a general comment but I mean
the other issues that y l pointed out I
wouldn't disagree with them in the uh
there's been a tremendous amount of hype
climate change implication for almost
every extreme weather event and most of
it is not scientifically based it's hype
and exaggeration and I'm saying this is
someone who who works on this in an
intimate way
and Lionel just just on the heating a
housekeeping there for viewers regular
viewers of spectator TV they'll know
that you're not one to regularly use
your heating system yes
no we're not running our heating system
and certainly not when it's you know 72
degrees Fahrenheit
um which to me is after after the winter
without heating is Toasty
but the secret is to turn the heat off
and let the fan go and that can be that
can really improve your air so that
that's that's something you might think
about
thanks for the tip yeah
at night
now let's go back to the column Lionel
you make another point which is actually
government regulation could have been a
factor in this can you explain what it
is in terms of controlled fires well
this is uh from a report in the New York
Times
um
which is very raw raw on climate change
so this is admission against interest
but one of the problems going on in
Canada uh is in order to do a controlled
burn you have to get through this
Thicket of regulations and it's so
difficult and it's so time consuming
that the narrow window of of
ideal conditions it needs to be
relatively still and not too hot
um
that that window closes by the time you
get through all the paperwork so uh
they're doing a lot of fewer controlled
Burns than they used to and
you know they're they're underfunding
the
um forest service and uh
they're just not doing a very good job
of managing their forests and
it's very similar to the problem in
California
which is doing exactly the same thing
and that's of course the the
land of Regulation not cliff do you
think there is a tendency with some of
these um events that come up to almost
talk about it in terms of climate change
which clearly can be a factor and when
some of the time at least uh sometimes
can be government handling government
preparedness government regulations and
it almost can distract from that type of
accountability
well it depends what you're talking
about
um in in terms of the uh the forest
issues the wildfires this is one in
which uh government mismanagement on
both sides of the Border have profoundly
undermined the situation so it's just
not Canada the United States I'm very
aware of what's happening in California
Pacific Northwest
and the the forests are radically
different than they were 150 years ago
and a lot of that is due to you know
suppression of fire not allowing Harvest
of the of the trees we have a forests
that used to be sparsely populated now
are densely populated with this
understory and they burn
catastrophically now so so for the From
The Far Side
mismanagement is is is right in the
center of it all
um you know that's going to be less of a
case in in other extreme weather events
you know like a heat wave or a cold wave
the the government intervention is is
less profound
this do you think in the scientific
Community there is a consensus there or
views like this approaching
uncontroversial in the forest community
and I know people and I go to all the
talks you know there there is a
consensus that we have mismanaged the
forests in the Western United States and
other places so I think the Forest
Community the the forestry Community uh
there is a consensus of course if you go
out of that Community into the climate
change Community or the climate
activists uh there's a consensus in the
opposite direction
and Lionel just finally uh do you think
that there should be more transparency
or Clarity from world leaders when it
comes to talking about the causes of
some of these uh incidents in a sense
for example I'm thinking of some of the
comments recently from Justin Trudeau I
would have more regard for the messaging
if it were more nuanced
and uh and it isn't it isn't ever and
when you constantly attribute every
single
rained off picnic
to climate change you make people
dubious of your expertise
um
and
that's my main message this stuff is
backfiring
um
and my other main message is that we're
losing an appreciation for the
difference between climate and weather
now it's true that climate in the great
big picture is this the sum total of all
the weather
but we do have two different words for a
reason and the most interesting thing
about writing this column for me was
looking up a graph of the temperature of
the earth which they have you know
geologists have put together uh over the
last half a million years it was
fascinating and one of the things that's
fascinating is first off the the
amplitude that is a huge variation in
the average temperature and also the
regularity with which every hundred
thousand years the temperature is swoops
down and goes down to about five degrees
Celsius
and then it
goes steeply up again
and we we have been on one of those
steep upward trajectories for the last
22 000 years
and almost all of that time was without
any
industrialization nope you know gas
powered uh power plants
um
and that gave me a sense of respect for
the bigger system that we're constantly
commenting on and in truth the periods
of time that we're talking about are
geologically
almost non-existent and
while I'm uh I try to keep an open mind
on this whole issue
uh I find that the perspective I get
from taking
of step back and looking at
the last half million years I find it
um I find it refreshing and it makes me
um keep an eye outside all the rhetoric
um can I comment on that yeah please do
sure a Lionel you know I understand what
you're saying but what you're saying is
not quite right and you've got to be
very careful here
um you know there we have this
variability due to ice ages over long
periods of time
um and that's true there's all kinds of
sources of variability there's this ice
age and out of the Ice Age so the
interglacials uh there's El Nino La Nina
a smaller periods of time there's all
kinds of Cycles in the atmosphere but
that doesn't mean the global warming
issue is not a real one
um it is true that greenhouse gases will
warm the planet and can warm it
relatively quickly so I mean we've got
to be careful just because there's been
variations that doesn't mean we don't
have to worry about the issue I think
the the the key understanding here is
that global warming is slowly warming
the planet we are slowly warming the
planet but that is not necessarily
producing this whole uh collection of
extremes
that the media is has has fixated on the
I I like to use the term the golden rule
of of uh climate change and that is the
greater the extreme the smaller
percentage of it is from climate change
natural variability can produce extremes
and so you know we we go in and out of
ice ages that's true but that does not
mean that human cause global warming is
not something that we should ignore or
is or is absolutely unimportant uh I I
think there's a middle ground here where
the truth is I broadly agree that that
there is a middle ground and if we heard
more from the Middle Ground
um
the the messaging would be more
persuasive I think we're being treated
like idiots
thank you Lionel thank you cliff
[Music]